this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 18.
with Echo Charles and me knock on
willink
good evening Echo good evening all right
so I was got asked this like multitude
of times especially I was on the Jordan
Peterson podcast a little bit ago and I
talked a bunch about writing and I also
talked about reading and then obviously
read the books for the podcast all the
time is what's the procedure look like
how am I doing this what am I doing
what's the procedure for reading the
book
so
there's also the procedure of selecting
a book for the podcast so I get sent so
many books and then books lead to other
books and then
I end up with a lot of books I get I
have a lot of books now and I can't read
them all because I have more books than
I than
you know we only do one one Jocko
podcast a week and I have more books
than that so I got to figure out which
book is going to be so
the first thing I do is I do an
assessment
of the book look you know somebody sends
me a book from World War II from Nam
right for World War one from the rep
from whatever they sent you know
somebody suggests a book I read about a
book you know I get the I'm doing
research for one book and I pull the
string on one of those books and I find
another book and I look at the
bibliography and I find another book and
it's written first person so you can see
where this comes from I mean the books
the resources out there are unlimited I
have
my default by the way my default mode is
order it
that's my default mode I'm gonna order
it but then on top of all the books that
I order
people send me books
so first I do a little assessment I can
almost guarantee you I'm going to open
it up and read like the first
page
and see what it's see what see how it
hits see how it lands you can tell you
can kind of get a feeling right there
you're like oh dang I'm already kind of
sucked into this thing
then I know this might sound like
spoiler alert but I'll go to the end of
the book and see what kind of closing
last couple Pages like where are we at
where'd this end up how's this finishing
and then I'll start like looking through
the book in the middle and start looking
for
how is this thing written and I'll look
for a spot to read you know about
maybe it's an actual battle maybe it's
after a battle but I'll look for
something like that you know I'll be
looking for keywords as I'm scanning
I'll be looking for Mortar five right
I'll be looking for bayonets fixed I'll
be looking for stuff like that to find
out what and then I'll start reading
that section and see how well it's
written and
and that's kind of
look so many of the books are good
so many books are great
but
I can't read them all and so I got to
make kind of a decision based on that
procedure right now right there the
opening the closing and then sort of a
sampling of The Middle
and then okay so once I decide all right
we're going in with this book we're
gonna do this I occasionally I'll
misjudge I've probably misjudged five
books so far where I
old read the opener read the closing
read a middle part like yeah this is
legit and then I read it and I was like
well you know I got let's say 42 pages
into it and I'm like no I misjudged it
put it on the put it on the other pile
are you at Liberty to say which ones
those were not really but none of them
were no one sent me a book where I was
like oh this is good no it actually
right like their book yeah no one like
doing something like that but I've
definitely had books where
some historical I can there was one book
that I read
that I really wanted to do a certain
subject
and I got a book that seemed like it
would be right and I invested probably
50 pages into it kept waiting for it to
and one of the key components was it was
a it wasn't a first person book so it
was an account right it was a historical
account which we've done some historical
accounts but if if there's enough first
person accounts in the historical
account then it can be used this one
didn't have really much for first person
no quotes you know Lance corporal Smith
said boom and you got two pages of
dialogue from that's Corporal Smith
getting it you know what I mean so
that's
so I've I've that's been a couple that
I've walked away from you know Midstream
but generally I do pretty good generally
I do a pretty good assessment and so
then what I do then I read the book when
I read the book the first time I'm go
I'm reading the entire thing and I'm
anything that's cool good impactful
meaningful lesson highlight I'm
highlighting I have orange highlighters
by the way yellow to light
orange is good I understand
so I go through the orange highlighter
read it and I'll some some books I'm
freaking highlighting all kinds I mean
it gets so I have to control myself
sometimes and pull back a little bit
because I can get crazy with the
highlight and then I'm thinking I'm just
gonna read a freaking audiobook here and
just read the whole book don't want to
do that
so I I'll highlight it and but sometimes
I am highlighting whole pages sometimes
I've just got two three four pages of a
battle scene that's epic and I'm like
yup I'm reading this whole thing that's
all there is to it so I'll highlight the
whole book then I kind of think about it
and
um
as far as the podcast goes
as far as podcast goes then then when
it's time to record the podcast then I
go through it again and I go and I have
these red pens these red like fine tip
pens and I'll outline and mark up
exactly what I am actually going to read
on the podcast and then arrows that lead
me to the next section and areas that
I'm not going to read and so that's how
I end up doing that and I have like
little marks for notes if I've got some
note about something or you know they
mention a general's name and then I got
a note in there I use a bunch of
stickies and all this crap
but
there's still something that's that's
that I have learned I would say about
reading
and it's been primarily from doing the
podcast
which is how I'm actually reading the
book and I think I did this before but I
did it subconsciously now I do it
consciously when I'm reading a book
it's not really a book that I'm reading
it's either a story that I'm hearing
from someone first person in my head
like I'm hearing this story
or oddly enough it's a story that I am
telling
so I'm reading it as if I'm telling the
story that I'm the person that lived it
which is weird right so I'm actually
reading this as if it's me and I'm gonna
tell the story to you
or I'm actually like in the mindset of
I'm living what's on the page
so
that's to me is
how I am really connecting with what I'm
reading
is I'm I'm in that frame of mind
I also read and I know this this
actually is not good I read at the speed
that I talk just about which sucks
because it takes me a long time to read
stuff
but that means that it when I'm reading
it it's like someone's telling me a
story or it's like I'm telling someone a
story so it's more engaging for me in my
brain and then I have the overlays right
I have the the conscious and
subconscious overlays of
extreme ownership of cover move and
simple and prioritize and execute and
decentralized command and dichotomy so
I've got those overlays and so those
things are I'm I'm scanning for those
things I'm looking for them or not
consciously looking for them like oh
that's cover move right there oh that's
you know oh that's a simple plan that's
gonna work I'm doing that so I've got
that additional overlay that additional
context to what I'm reading
and I'm also looking for outliers so I'm
looking for things that don't match up
with my theoretical principles I
remember when I read one of tilts books
and he split forces and I was like dang
I don't know this doesn't sound like a
good and I asked him on the podcast I
said you know I'm I I felt weird asking
him right because I'm like man it's tilt
bro
and I said hey tell you know here you
are you're going in this jungle
situation and you split forces I said I
was like I was like you know I always
kind of thought it was a bad thing
because it was the only time I did it
and it worked out horribly I was like
yes I ain't gonna love you sometimes you
do have to split forces but you have to
use caution when you do it so I have
that context of what I know what I
believe
than the outliers from what I know and
what I believe and and when I say what I
believe that means it's what I believe
but I also realize that books can
present questions to what I believe
which is awesome because if I get a
question of what I believe that's a
positive thing because now I'm gonna
either learn more about my belief being
correct or maybe my belief is incorrect
and I'm open-minded to that and I
actually want it
so I have those overlays and then I have
the overlays of when I'm reading how
things fit together that I'm reading and
this is on multiple levels in the book
itself when you're reading in a book
you gotta remember that that's a
complete world right and that page that
section that you're reading is connected
to everything else that's in there and
sometimes we get
because you're you're detached from it
you turn the page it's like we're not
thinking about that anymore so I
consciously am thinking about hey this
is actually happening in the context of
this whole entire book
and then how does this whole entire book
fit in the context of other books about
this particular battle this particular
War this particular situation
war in general how does it fit in
how does this compare to the whole world
what's going on in the world
and then how does it compare to my world
what I've been through what I've
experienced the knowledge that I have or
don't have
and
and what I'm looking for obviously what
I'm looking for is trying to find
lessons
find new lessons possibly relearn
lessons that I've already learned
learned or reinforced the same lessons
and then all of this provides me with
perspective so that I can more
holistically understand
Human Nature
that's what that's what I'm doing that's
what we're doing and you know there's a
there's speaking of books I was just
reading a book and there's a quote in
there from Otto von Bismarck who's a
German chancellor for three Wars
and he's always he's always in these
pictures with these kind of uh
militaristic General Uniforms on you
know with the shoulder gold shoulder
pads the big all that stuff he was like
a reservist for a few weeks or something
he wasn't like and he apparently it was
begrudgingly a soldier for a very short
period of time but you know once you're
the chancellor you're like you know what
I want that freaking General outfit well
there's a
there's a book by b.h Liddell Hart who's
a whole nother we have a whole
we have a whole
library of books from him that he wrote
he was a really uh
profoundly impactful British military
Soldier officer fought in World War One
wounded uh sent back sent back again I
mean just he he's went through a lot and
he had an incredibly
fluid mind an incredible understanding
of military tactics and I we haven't
even broached it's one of those things
where there's a couple books right now
I've got in the waiting that I'm wait
that I I'm like hey when I open when I
go on this it's going to be it's gonna
be
it's going to take four five six seven
podcasts to do
and so I've got some of those books in
the waiting right now BH will know hard
is one of them
um but the quote is that I'm getting to
that I was reading in this book today
fools say that they learn from
experience I prefer to profit from
others experience so what does that mean
that means read that means put yourself
into the situation in the book so you
can learn from other people's
experiences and you don't have to go
through it yourself
so there you go a little bit on reading
seems like that extends to essentially
listen
right to others because yeah
so I tell my kids like a little I don't
know if what do you call Mantra I don't
know whatever it is what are the three
three things that make you smart
listen read and
rest
you can't listen and read and not rest
you gotta rest okay fair enough um
actually it's sleep so three things that
make you strong are
working out eating good food and resting
things that Mickey
uh smart is listen read rest sleep sorry
anyway the thing I made up with my kids
I'm sure that look it's not perfect but
I wanted them to sort of remember it so
I want to ask them it they can kind of
recite it and understand you know yeah
there there's I was trying to think of
what you're missing and and it didn't
at first I was like oh that was legit
right listen read sleep that's really
good
um and then I thought like honestly I
started what about math right like I
literally thought like what about math
yeah and so it's almost like so that
made me think well what can you say to
someone that's short and concise that
will also make them realize that they
have to kind of learn and drill and
practice yeah you know what I mean and
then the other thing is questions right
how do you get smart you get smart by
asking questions so
those are good I like I like those are
good fundamentals for your kids yeah
they're very good fundamentals you get a
very good grade on your fundamental
concepts for your kids on those two
factors solid yeah I felt like listening
is one of those ones where it's
essentially you're learning from others
and what I had in mind anyone was listen
to your parents listen to your teachers
you know that whole thing I liked asking
questions one for sure which kind of
brings you back to listening because
once you ask the question you better
start listening kind of a thing I guess
now that I'm trying to analyze it but
yeah felt pretty good about it I guess
yeah it's a good start we'll say that
like and I don't mean that even in a
even in a in a condescending way I don't
I mean it's like a legitimate good start
yeah
how do you say good start and and have
it not be condescending
you just need to say that's a really
good start you know what that's a great
Foundation to build upon even that is a
little bit negative right yeah most of
them do especially if you're paying
attention to the idea that it could be
condescending they all seem pretty
Congress even when you're like I like
where you're I like where you're going
with that like you know even that it's
like a consolid start you got there just
give them the full whenever I tell Dave
good deal yeah whenever I tell Dave that
he that he'll ask me like oh how was
that I'll be like oh solid
you think that I'm he thinks I'm you
know yep he thinks that's a that's a c
that's a c plus yeah and I told you this
plenty times in Hawaii solid means good
it's like excellent essentially yeah
yeah guys solid right there yeah or or
that was a solid job or whatever it
means excellent just a subtle difference
yeah well apparently in Carl's Bad Carol
from California it means like marginal
barely acceptable
um that's interesting how you like
you know you know what honestly he's
right
with in some cases like if somebody does
a bad job and I don't wanna
make them feel
uh self-conscious which is gonna which
is going to
worsen their performance right I they
might say how was that I mean like I was
so solid man but no even less than that
they might be like how was I back oh
that was solid so I'm I'm I am doing
what he's talking about but usually with
the context of Dave
I'm like oh that was solid meaning
Hawaiian song
I mean not like perfect but yeah it's
not perfect but it's freaking solid yeah
just say legit you gotta say legit right
yeah essentially because solid is that
it's kind of like hey No One's Gonna
fire you for this job that you did it's
kind of like the uh kudos for a job done
it's like that not the well done it's
like done hey you did the job man done I
don't know I heard it once on the show
but
I don't know I don't know what Kudos
technically are either
um you you get like um the human nature
element like it makes you understand
human nature to read all these books and
stuff I always think of
um like while I'm listening I always
think of like the time frames you know
and if and especially the Iraq guys like
where the where they're the stuff that
they went through
was during the time that I was alive and
they'd say the date and I remember like
I remember exactly what I was doing on
that time at that time on that date or
whatever
and I get to realize like and you were
doing this while I was freaking here at
home watching this new show or whatever
and so it puts that into perspective and
it almost gives me like a little like a
like a weird almost like a GPS location
of where
I am you know in this whole freaking
thing in the context in the context
exactly it's weird man but yeah man it's
crazy check
um well we do have some questions from
the interwebs all right first question
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground